we had voices of reason i just don't
know how you can be so sure so quick
a proposal
claire will you marry me yes
and a beacon of light and gorgeousness
our lord and savior come to rescue us
all
surprise what are you doing here this is
you're the bachelorette season 16
episode four
with a proposal recap grab your glasses
it's time for roses and roses
i'm engaged i'm getting married
we're engaged jazz hands we're engaged
right now yeah
we're engaged oh my gosh engaged
we're engaged she's engaged
what is she she's engaged
they're engaged
[Music]
that was that was more than i thought it
would be
oh god
okay i need to clean this up
more pieces of confetti then date's
clear has gone on i'll tell you that
okay i'm gonna need a minute
[Music]
we're good we're engaged claire moss
oh everybody i'm lauren zema and claire
crowley
and dale moss are engaged they
are involved they are betrothed
after episode four it is an
unprecedented record for the franchise
i think i wait a lot a lot of years for
this now i have some concerns
it's wild right that we're here right
now i have a lot of
questions but i also think this is
positive
it is a good thing and we need a good
thing
so let's lean in
i felt it i accepted it i knew it
i accepted it what did you all think of
this
absolutely over the top episode
we have so much to get to because so
much
happened so i've poured so much wine in
my glass already it's a pre-pour we
don't have time to pour
let's just get to it
oh pretty good oh
okay like am i becoming roses and rose
am i morphing into the brand the
aesthetic
like i'm literally wearing roses and
rose here i i'm
sinking into the couch i'm becoming the
couch
let's get to it no group rolls for
nobody
so we are back we are picking up right
where we left off at the end of last
episode
episode three and here we are
in the situation that we're in but don't
drink for every time the guys are like
where are we why am i here we just need
to know what's going on
what the are you thinking right now
claire because you're not telling it
but we're gonna find out because chris
harrison is here to talk to claire
oh this is the blowing stuff up
conversation from the promo
you've just blown up the bachelorette
and what
did you think of this conversation we
need to talk
okay i was captivated it was so raw
so emotional so honest chris tells her
to be honest
he tells her to say how she feels he
says
no be totally
and completely honest with me no is that
another franchise first has he ever
sworn before
chris garrison don't
yeah scared so they're talking and
trying to figure out where claire's at
where is claire what are you feeling
she says dale shows up for her just
continually
shows up for me and remember in the very
first episode
which was only three episodes ago she
said that
her dad was all about showing up he
would always tell her to just show up
my dad would say i'm proud of you for
just showing up
that's the biggest part of it and
there's been some chatter because claire
was liking some tweets
about her allegedly being forced out of
the season
but we see it here claire says
that in her mind this process
is over so in your mind right now
is this over
yeah the process is over
yeah it's over yeah it's done it's done
we're done
okay finito what's over
the process it's done cheers it's done
congratulations you've just blown up the
bachelorette how do you feel about
claire's decision to say
i'm done i just want to go be with dale
let me know in the comments below i mean
it sounds
wild doesn't it totally
i'm like head over heels for dale but i
do want to give a little glass race to
some of the more grounded
commentary we did get this episode never
thought i'd say it i had to look up
who he was to remember cheers to kenny
the boy band manager for all the sane
things he said this episode
this has nothing to do with dale this is
on her she's wrapped up in
whatever is going on with dale she's not
even
giving anybody else in this house an
opportunity
it's almost like she doesn't care to
learn about anybody else like why
am i here there's not going to be a
cocktail party tonight chris harrison
goes
and he pulls dale away dale can i talk
to you outside real quick
yep thanks i was still at this point
wondering how are we doing this um but i
guess it's with a dinner date
tonight i have a dinner date with dale
and claire walks
out and a dink
claire is looking good also festively
dressed you know
red roses the bachelorette is she
dressed for a proposal
i'm engaged i'm getting married
she might as well be because she says
she is in love
with dale and
i'm so in love with him
but we get into this dinner and i do see
how claire and dale connect you know
and i loved dale's responses to a lot of
what claire said she tells him
that he reminds her of her dad years and
years and years
of like praying for a man that had those
qualities that my dad had
and instead of even talking about
himself in that moment dale just says
i want to know more about your parents
i've wanted to know more about like your
parents and their relationship
like why you are the way you are
as wild as all of this has been
you guys if claire and dale really found
real love with each other then that was
the point
so cheers to that
i'm so falling in love with you like i'm
falling in love with you through this
process
they're both in love
they're in love
what are they they're in love what you
keep
up my heart is open and i'm not gonna
fight that
oh my gosh and it was a bit of a relief
to see because i don't want to see
claire get hurt that dale
was totally on the same page as her when
we met
i felt love was your mind blown
by that i knew he was into her but dale
says no
i'm also falling in love with you like
i'm falling in love with you through
this process
i've also been wanting to share this
i've been dying to share this with you
this is the simulation is this the
matrix
what's serendipitous simulation 2020
what's up i don't know where i am where
are we
[Music]
i mean claire and dale do seem a bit
blown away by all of it too
don't drink every time they said what is
happening
what is happening it is what it is it's
i don't know
what is happening i mean i don't even
know what is
happening what is happening life
love what's going on
safety on the couch you know i don't
know what's happening
but let's just sit in it it's nice love
connection 20 20.
and then and then and
then claire said something that really
truly
gave me goosebumps got me cold i was
icing over with the chills
and to every single person who has ever
told me
to settle and that the man i'm looking
for is not out there
like i'm having dinner with him right
now
[Music]
you can't write this oh but then things
are getting hot dale and claire have
woken up together
in bed honestly what do you think is
gonna happen next
i have no idea i really haven't thought
about it
oh i guess it wasn't a proposal it was a
fantasy suite we're on the fantasy suite
episode
so they wake up together after things
have clearly happened
and dale leaves with us bye
bye which i kind of loved no sign of him
yet
no sign of them yeah no signs of dale oh
but we forgot about the other guys again
they
are uh back over there wherever they are
just trying to solve the mystery
they're putting together the clues
they're like it's been 18 hours
almost been gone for 18 hours we haven't
seen dale
where is he still asking
where is claire i don't know i don't
know dude
i don't know what's happening it's just
a big old question mark right now
and when we have questions who comes in
with answers
chris harrison hello hey how's it going
you know what everybody don't drink for
every chris harrison conversation we had
this episode what's up we need to talk
there's going to be
hopefully a proposal today she's going
to be waiting
for a proposal you have to trust that
you showed up we are so proud of you
your new bachelorette is on her way here
right now honestly the man is working
hard
chris is now talking to claire about how
the fantasy suite went
so oh my gosh how was last night
amazing but while we've had all these
questions claire just has answers
don't drink for every definitive thing
claire said
about dale yes he's in love with me he's
exactly what i've been looking for
i would be so honored
to be with this guy for the rest of my
life he's my person
and i will say that as she's saying all
this uh don't drink for how
wide chris harrison's eyes are getting
yes he's in love with me
i told you he's my person
this is unprecedented to say the least
proposal
[Music]
yeah i think he had uh questions as well
but he's a man who likes to have answers
solutions to be proactive so he
basically says claire
we sped right through this let's keep
our foot on the gas
it's proposal time the next step
proposal let's do it tonight when are we
doing this
tonight
what is time a continuum
a moving and yet ever stopping force
bounding through the universe expanding
folding inward
and poofing out again confusing us with
its parameters
and how we can measure it what we know
about it what we don't
know about it
[Music]
and claire goes back to this when you
know you know
things you know when you know
and i know and i'm not saying that
claire doesn't know what she wants
i'm just saying as i've been saying that
how do you know that this is what you
want if you don't know this that well
you know hello hi guys
so claire goes and speaks to the guys
and basically says
uh it's gonna be a dale for me
dogs it's definitely not for me though
and doe drink for every one of their
blank leaning
what the stairs dale
but again we do have some voices of
reason this episode
this time blake is back with his beard
and he
says i don't know how you can be so
sure so soon i just don't know how you
can be so sure so quick and
[Music]
it worries me for you a little bit oh
blake you're so silly
we don't worry about time anymore
oh and then things are getting heated
kenny wants an apology
to the group you should apologize to the
group
you know kenny's a boy band manager and
i wondered without his boy band
did these guys become his boys and he's
got to manage
the situation and claire's kind of like
what am i apologizing for can you tell
me what i'm apologizing for though
because i'm sitting here like i'm not
gonna apologize for
love did you think that claire should
have apologized to the group
i did i thought she could have just done
it for good measure just told these guys
look i am so sorry that this did not go
the way that you thought it was going to
that could have been the apology
but instead claire said i'll apologize
if i wasted your time
i'll apologize if i wasted your time
well you did
i'll apologize if i hurt you i'll
apologize if i hurt you
well i kind of think you did but i'm not
going to apologize for love
i'm not going to apologize for love no
you don't have to apologize for that but
did you apologize was this an apology
what did you think of the apology let me
know in the comments below
but cheers to the guys for many nice
responses they tell claire they'll be
happy for
her i just really appreciate you and i
really hope the best for you no matter
what
thank you cheers to all these awkward
goodbye hugs
and kinda cheers to claire saying that
she would miss them
i'm gonna miss you guys i don't think
she will
but things are not all well and good we
still have more tears ahead in our
times but speaking of time maybe it's
too late now to say
sorry and claire is instead crying to
producers why is she crying i'm
so confused i don't know are we already
on her and dale's first breakup what's
happened
claire goes and cries to the producers
about how hard it was
this is hard they're all like
amazing i think that's the reason to
talk to the guys and i was just sort of
sitting there feeling like
claire you're getting everything you
wanted
why are you crying
would you have cried let me know in the
comments below oh and chris harrison is
back with a virtual conversation he is
facetiming neil lane
claire came here to find love and she
did
he is going on facetime to get an
engagement ring
tonight i need to get the ring
today today today timely
by the way shameless plum
chris harrison just launched a wedding
band line so you can go check that out
they are so chic
and i helped name them but we only have
a second for elaine now we've gotta go
do another chris harrison conversation
with
dale and chris harrison is gonna tell
dale that claire broke up with all the
other guys today
claire broke up with all the other guys
today
i was like i didn't think about it like
that but i guess that's true
i guess she did break up with them don't
drink for every guy claire broke up with
i kind of forgot they were dating and
then
and then and then claire is
crying again am i being calloused you
guys let me know in the comments below i
just felt like claire
just enjoy it it's all working out it's
all okay
okay but we are going we are continuing
to speed we are moving at the speed of
light
we are the millennium falcon on our way
to blow up the dale star
there is a fire claire's in a white
dress
we are professing our
feelings and i promise you
i want to show up for you each and every
single day
and dale is proposing
[Music]
yes how do we all feel
who am i talking to oh you guys i'm
talking to you i'm sorry i was lost in
the space-time continuum
how do you feel about the fact that dale
proposed
i mean look again i want them both to be
happy but even dale says
and i quote it's wild right that we're
here right now
it's wild right that we're here right
now
yes yes dale looks at the ring
and it's like you're seeing it for the
first time he's like wow that's big
i need some shades on that
get some sunglasses out baby you're
gonna hurt your wrists carry this thing
around
only got a glimpse of it earlier before
i came out here and popped it on your
finger
and maybe my favorite moment they're
talking about their connection and
claire says
i felt it and dale says
i accepted it i felt it
i accepted it claire says i knew it dale
says
i accepted it i knew it i accepted it
yeah i did
time time
[Music]
i raised my glass to dale claire says
we're engaged
dale says now we got to put in the work
we're engaged
yeah now we get it put into work cheers
to that honestly my hope is
that they had this crazy connection and
that they really are a great match and
it happened very quickly
but no matter what kind of instant
attraction you have
no matter how much you have in common on
paper you still got to build the
relationship
learn how to communicate and have
experiences together through which you
see how the other person reacts
i guess dale's been watching the
bachelorette because he even quotes
becca kufrin
let's do the damn thing just do the damn
thing let's do the damn thing
dale you did you already did it
rings on her finger what did you guys
think of dale's tone it did seem unsure
but i don't blame him i think he's a
little trepidatious
but that doesn't mean that he's not all
in it means he's like
we're going down the path but let's look
around us you know let's
get a grip on our surroundings before we
barrel ahead
[Applause]
all right so claire and dale are gone
but chris harrison is still working he's
gonna do
two seasons in one it's a twofer a bogo
buy one get one i guess we keep
forgetting about these other guys
he's gotta go and tell them that dale
and claire are engaged
beardy blake is like i don't know if i
need drinks
or sleep or what i don't know if i need
like drinks or sleep or what
blake same same and here it is
it's happening it's happening it's
happening oh my god
okay it's happening everybody stay calm
chris tells them that their journey
isn't over
your journey is not over their journey
isn't over
oh these poor men their faces are
basically saying
i cannot take in any more information
what the hell is happening now they're
given the option to stay
each of you needs to make a decision but
in true bachelor fashion
a timeline they have to decide by
tonight
by tonight if you want to stay or you
want to go
now they don't know who they'd be
staying for they don't know who the new
bachelorette will be
at this point but guess who's clapping
and smiling and being positive about it
all
bennett personally i'm very very very
excited
[Music]
this is just a you know clean slate
bennett bennett
i just printed out a bunch of pictures
of bennett
but if bennett winds up single bennett
for paradise right
bachelor impaired it ben it in paradise
i had a lot of optimism about claire the
guys are debating this
do i want to go through all that again
like i don't know
and honestly what did you think of their
discussions
why wouldn't you stay at this point in
the world what was going on outside
of the laquinta resort and spa place
everything was shut down
what are you leaving for wouldn't you
have stayed let me know in the comments
below
oh and we are moving and grooving and
not stopping
[Applause]
everybody it's night one all over again
you're gonna start the bachelorette
right now
again did they just was it literally
dale was proposing and then they were
like okay
move a couple rose pedestals around it's
night one for tatiana we're gonna start
the bachelorette
right now again i think all the guys
showed up in their suits
i'm not sure i i started tuning out at
this point because i couldn't take in
any more information and i just wanted
to see tasha
oh and my wish came true it's the gift
that keeps on giving
it is time tasha is here
oh oh oh and i have gone from the gooses
to freezing
to cryogenically frozen in time to be
awakened in another year when things are
different
because you guys you guys
you guys tasha looked gorgeous
i was done truly what did you think of
tasha's night one look she looked
amazing
[Music]
so much has happened so much still to
come we get a teaser
and claire and dale are back it's just
been a dream come true
and they seem to still be together and
tasha's worried the guys will see her as
a second choice
some of the guys might view me as a
second choice i never want to feel that
way again
i don't think they will and chris
harrison has never been
in a bachelorette episode this much he
is back again to tell them
that everything's about to change
unfortunately everything is about to
change
okay
are you kidding me
what did you guys think i i think that
probably means new guys are gonna come
in
it has to be right we gotta give tasha a
new appetizer a new entree it can't just
be all the leftovers okay
it's cooking in the kitchen what you
doing over there mama oh and speaking of
food at the end we're watching claire
and dale make a salad and i don't need
that
but i do need you oh babes i am so
grateful for all of you
anytime i have time with you i am so
grateful and have so much fun so we will
be back
next week we have had so much patience
like patience for this moment puns
abound
time spinning all around i love you so
much
i am available on cameo tick tock
twitter and instagram if you would like
to connect more
and now that we have all learned how to
master playing with the boundaries of
the space-time continuum
i'm just going to disappear bye
[Music]
oh god this is
what is it a party i don't know
okay oh it's in the wine